well I've been a terrible liar on those
subjects and and what what I tried to
convey to the American people is
I things that were untrue is what he
tried to convey made mistakes of
allowing the pressures of what I thought
needed to be done in order to this you
guys did you see that his mistake was he
let his misunderstanding of pressure to
say things that weren't true
make him lie like it's this is like an
as I apologize if people were offended
this wasn't about tricking anybody this
wasn't about just it's it's sensible no
no no no no no let me finish about
tricking let me finish it wasn't about
tricking to the people this was about
getting accepted by the party right he
had to lie because otherwise the
Republican Party wouldn't accept him
um